Film Courage: Having gone through the experience
of meeting Jen [his film’s screenwriter]
and going to this pitch fest, what advice
can you give other screenwriters on meeting
a filmmaker and pitching their script?
Jay Silverman, photographer and director of
OFF THE MENU: You know, it’s no different
than being an photographer or a director.
You don’t have an opportunity to explain
yourself, it’s either on the page or it’s
not on the page.
Now if I had met Jen [Goldson, the writer
of Jay’s film OFF THE MENU] and she was
quote-unquote “difficult” just at the
get-go, I probably would have never even read
the script.
So I think having a little bit of communication
skills is a gift in that regard.
I also think stereotypically I’m not like
the stereotype, I’m open to collaborating.
And if you find out right at the beginning
that the person isn’t…here’s a great
example a woman who…Bethany [Cerrona, Jay’s
producer] found me a wonderful script about
hate and the challenge of working with groups
that hate and it was a really, really well-written
movie.
It was also a play and I had wished in hindsight
that I didn’t spend an hour on the phone
with the writer when they said “Oh, one
more thing I forgot to tell you is I have
to direct this myself.”
So I felt that this was something that should
have come out in the first ten seconds because
to me it’s not uncommon for a screenwriter
to say “I don’t want anybody else to direct
this but me.”
I only produce movies that I direct and the
outcome of it is that is I’ve learned that
lesson now.
Film Courage: So if that is a requirement
or special requirements like I want very little
edits done, get this out right away?
Jay: I would pass.
I mean, it’s just not worth it.
There’s too many…the independent film
business is so convoluted with waste and waste
and then when you finally get to the execution…here’s
a wonderful example, my other producer Will
Newman who helped produce this movie, he was
not just an incredible collaborator to this
movie but he was the hatchet man in a positive
way.
He would come in and say, no disrespect to
Jen’s material but she’s got 56 characters
and he knew right away…bingo…that that
was going to translate into a portion of the
budget that was disproportionate with what
we had.
And what does that mean in English?
The only affordable amount of characters we
could have in his opinion was between 20 and
25 characters.
And I know that sounds crazy but any independent
filmmaker is going to come in front of the
same moment that I came in front of when you
go “Do you really need that character to
walk in the door and go Hey, you’ve got
a phone call.”
That character is a SAG talking actor and
that’s going to cost you X amount of dollars.
And you put 40 more of those in the movie
and you’ve made a movie that you’re not
going to be able to afford and it’s crazy
and I know that you are interviewing me about
creativity but if you can get this stuff off
the table before you start talking creativity,
you’ll have (in my opinion) a more controllable
project.